[Music]
hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to three scary games i
want to show you something and don't be
worried
this is long key now i know a lot of you
are afraid of lunki but it's fine
i made lunky uh lucky's just a drawing
that i came up with
so long ago that i don't even really
remember when i did it
um i think it was i made it like uh
what did i make um
i don't remember
[Music]
i'm i'm made
i made you right
[Music]
this is the arcade and it's based off of
stranger things which actually now that
i think about it
i don't remember there being did i see
something was there something in the top
right over there and if there wasn't
lexie and put it in
very scary i don't remember ever playing
a stranger things based
video game i'm sure there are but i'm
also pretty sure they crack down on
those pretty intensely for intellectual
property rights but either way we're
gonna play it
see where this goes i like arcades ooh
all right oh it's lovely
i don't like it you know i thought i
would be able to get a little uh you
know into
into some games before the freakiness
would start but apparently not all right
plenty of pac-man space invaders street
fighters
good stuff oh oh that don't look good
potato chips hello oh
can i get any of that no oh
oh man oh whoa mama okay all right
okay i'll do it i'll do it oh no
how in the hell is this based off of
stranger things or is that a dollar it
was a lie oh
oh oh that's how oh
the arcade that literally says stranger
things the black
tentacles really uh really make this um
appealing yellow nope
all right that's reliable and
trustworthy
oh good oh great oh this is good
stuff oh this you just love
well it still seems fine is there
nothing wrong with this maybe i was
supposed to open the cabinet at the top
of the stairs and maybe i was actually
supposed to be able to go through that
or get a key out of that that's probably
what it is
oh god oh no
that is fine
this is fine well this is fine
no this is fine
oh wow well
uh that's something uh i guess i'll
leave now
unless outside is also the upside down
and there's a giant monster standing
there
oh there is oh boy oh yeah hey
yeah come on in come on
oh ah that's all good it's all good baby
it's all good oh
oh that was it oh that was so short
that was so short but it was good i
guess it was kind of a recreation of the
show actually but still
i liked that that was very good hey they
just wanted it to be an experience and
you know they made the experience pretty
good
i'm not gonna lie that was that was not
too shabby i thought there was gonna be
more to it but hey
spooky all right moving on
this is a workplace with no people
or something like that i think that was
the name of it
oh
what a lovely intro beautiful
man this city is depressing not gonna
lie
it's a a real downer
artsy
i don't know what the moral implication
of this story is or i don't know what
the setting is or i don't know anything
other than that it's a workplace with
apparently no people oh is this where i
work
god it looks boring am i moving
where have i seen this style before also
why does he look
like me right now like immediately now
am i crazy
yeah whatever it's perfect all right
let's go in this building
oh this oh i don't like the ambiance hey
boss okay
let's see i'm throwing a jump scare
okay i just wanted to clear the nerves a
little bit another one
all right we're good just need to clear
the air now that we're desensitized
we're not gonna be scared by anything
that happens now
okay what's behind door number one this
my job
lexington one more jump scare please
okay thank you
okay wow this uh if i if i was am i
going to interview here is where i go
every day
oh this is so shockingly normal for what
i just transitioned to
where am i going where am i okay
this is the timeout chair i'm gonna go
to the timeout chair a little bit
uh yeah push that into the shadows
didn't know you're physically active
this is worth it there we go oh damn it
well that's good enough
all right er like do i go backwards
faster than i go oh
do you think you can cry you think
you can cry you can cry
you think you can cry on the job oh boss
oh hey boss hey what's up boss
f uh sorry man whatever my respects my
dude my respects
manager they're all gone well maybe you
stopped paying the power bill i don't
know
whatever what f i f'd
they're all gone okay so what about that
boss
i'm still here your favorite employee
that always okay they're all gone okay
uh
all right dude all right
oh boy um okay well
do our it's uh uh bye i guess
um where am i oh
[Music]
no
all right sure fine hello i'm the last
person here
don't believe what he says
what the guy who was crying why would he
lie
get out of here as fast as you can
well i kind of believe him then because
if he said
everyone was gone that means i should
probably get out of here right all right
i'm getting out of here as fast as i can
you know i'm gonna
i'm gonna do a horror movie like not not
the usual and i'm running
as fast as i can out of the building
you must be here for the job interview
oh i assumed i was but maybe not
follow me no
no
no okay well then i guess i you
[Applause]
hey boss you looking for a new employee
hey what's up boss
hey how you doing buddy hey
i do move faster back oh hey everyone
oh hey gang what's up my news hey jerry
ultimate lily alice
oh jetsworth stunko
there's stinky man
sorry sorry uh sorry bret
all right chad
you oh uh oh
where did i go you oh wait what what
what what what what
oh gr
this is faster this is much faster this
is much faster
all right hey boss
this is very uh the
flow of this office is great
listen i'm a man who really likes to get
down to business hey
let me slap my hand on this desk hey
what's up bud hey uh you're gonna give
me this job
and not only that you're gonna give me a
raise first day of the job because i
am worth it and you're worth it to me
go through the door to your what'd you
say boss didn't even hear but i'm going
my right you're right our right
you whoa all right i'm a go-getter
so i'm gonna go get okay
[Music]
is this kind of like some kind of like
symbolic piece about
the state of corporate america or work
in general is this is this something to
be said about that is this like hogs in
a machine
on a conveyor belt that gives us a ride
from birth to death
and nothing that we do will deviate us
unless we choose to
step off the treadmill of adequacy and
step into excellence
yes sing sing my fellow workers sing
today we rise up and oh
[Music]
oh god
oh hey hey what's up man f yeah
it's perfect
[Music]
f f f
f f
f it really i think it is i think it's
something about carbon copies
cogs and i think i was dead right i
think i was absolutely right no sarcasm
oh
beautiful but also not a revelation
the industrial revolution we've known
nothing but cogs in the machine
but not bad i like the styling i like
the camera angles and stuff like that
uh i got nothing else to say
pretty good we're good lixie and hit him
with another jump scare
this game is called leanie boog
literally that's the name
lenny boog not making that up i don't
know if that's in reference to like some
mythological entity seems to be some
kind of a wolf man
so i'm going to play uh laney boog
you need to use headphones well
press an oldie to interact with nearby
objects okay
hey thanks how to play the main task is
to survive as long as pos
i don't like that task you need to
listen carefully to where the monster
runs and try to close the window and
time oh i hate that
so that it cannot climb into the house
to close the window you need to
hold down the e button this demo is
impossible to pass
click this button if you're ready to
start the game ah
i don't like this i don't like it
already okay
oh i'm here i am now okay um
what am i listening for oh no no stop
ladyboog
how long do i hold it for okay until it
goes i can't hear
thing oh
oh oh lanie baby is that upstairs
oh no no no no no blaze ladybug
well that's a problem um
[Music]
yeah uh-huh all right
i wish i could run i wish i could run
hey what's up bud hey pal
hey listen
[Music]
not today
where what where what is that
i don't know what that means oh i'm
doomed
[Music]
there's more okay try it again
come on okay so i'm guessing the first
couple
definitely downstairs oh yeah
hey bud hey sorry
no the main problem is that i have to
keep an ear out
i have to listen closely or else i'm
never going to hear him
hi no thank you
i literally don't know how much time i
have for those
but probably not that much
okay good good good good great great
this is great
that's good stuff we don't want any
leanie boo
leaning baby
hey hi pal okay we're doing good
this might be a new record for us which
is great
but everyone has to be very quiet
[Music]
oh
i don't know why that scared me so much
i knew he was behind me
sound is my weapon sound is my death the
sound
i hear is me hitting the ground dead
it's
not good sound sir
i'm i'm probably gonna die this time i'm
just this is just gonna be a death one
right but i i gotta find out
what exactly is down here what is
this what is that
what are these what is this what is this
what the hell is that oh i mean he's
gonna come get me and
this is gonna be moderately terrifying
oh boy
um
yeah this game's kind of impossible i'm
gonna give it one more try and i'm
really gonna try but i do not know why
that one window did not close when i got
to it that
made it difficult okay try hard mode
here we go okay so you can
hear so you can definitely hear where
he goes absolutely
okay you can here okay you can
definitely hear him
oh no second floor
oh god wait what the hell i wasn't ready
for that where was that oh no
we no
oh no hey there you are oh let me just
close the window for you there
oh hey bud why don't you just jump right
on me
hey come on dude come on val
okay so that was a good try um this game
very difficult uh this game big hard
this game huge hardness but cool concept
legitimately even reading about what i
had to do
scared me because i i could tell that i
wasn't gonna like it
but i mean i like it as a game i just
didn't like it as an experience
in in a good way meaning it's scary so
very scary
i am excited to see where this goes
because i like the mechanic
it's panic inducing and i i just want to
see where it developed so yeah
cool stuff yeah can't wait to see more
all right moving on
this is uh deep fog i think this is just
a demo
oh it's just chapter one coming soon
wait for it thank you for patient
okay let's go to dinner
good god what is happening
this is the spookiest bop i've ever
heard chapter one playtime is about 50
minutes no save okay well i won't die
then
there is news on tv about fog city
missing person cases
the fire in the mountains fog city is
not calm recently
okay telephone
it seems to be only used to call
supervisor okay where am i
today is my second day at work it's best
to check the staff rules again
fox city cemetery number four staff
rules this is a cemetery only for
unidentified corpses
okay except corpses with no questions
i'm not 100 sure about that company
policy but i'll accept it put it in the
coffin berry coffin push across it
i love a simple job oh yeah nothing
suspect about this only bury the coffin
by day and take lucy on patrol at night
who's lucy remember to feed lucy and
treat her well if you have any questions
call the supervisor
hmm i'll keep that in mind take lucy on
patrol after feeder
okay who's lucy oh
where's lucy oh lucy no
axe for chopping wood hmm what is the
uses of firewood
to light a fire this is the bathroom i
don't want to use the bathroom now
i do oh wow
oh boy seems like there's a deep fog
about huh i gotta admit their
their use of audio and this is very good
a commemorative bronze statue the
inscriptions on the statue were worn
away a gentleman in a hat
seems to be the founder of this cemetery
yeah maybe that guy should be arrested
i'm pretty sure a cemetery just for
unidentified corpses is no kind of good
at all it's a bit scary to see at night
yeah
where lucy lucy lucy
two coffins were already filled the
rules say burying coffins during the day
i heard they were burned to death in the
mountain fire
if i don't see the corpse directly it's
not scary well sure hope that don't
happen coffin cart
and that's all i have to say on that
matter oh lucy
lucy lucy
lucy time to patrol oh
lucy oh my god chewing the bone
what should i do take the bone pet lucy
pet lucy lucy looks happy why must the
nightguard take care of this too oh
you i hope you die a horrible death i'm
sorry that was a little extreme but it's
a horror game and i'm sure you will die
a horrible death so i was just banging
on that let's go lucy
let you have dinner after patrol no
dinner before patrol
lucy suddenly feels alarmed what's wrong
even if i say your stupid dog there's no
need to be mad at me
is there something wrong with the gate
the gate is still locked
oh what happened to lucy why did i leave
lucy
what is that what is that delivery
digiorno lucy come over here now oh hey
lucy you're fine okay i'm i'm
i'm happy you're okay what is this
sniffing around it's delicious blood
me thinks a big bag it's blood lucy is
no longer barking there should be no
yeah but when
bags of corpses are falling out of the
sky i'm kind of concerned
there's a note on the bag let's see what
should i check first uh the note
someone threw a bag of corpses i'm gonna
read the note let me see what's in the
note
the note reads sorry to bother you so
late to avoid accidents
i've cut off all their heads have a nice
day
whoo are you
h this is killing and abandoning bodies
i would never look into the bag
i have to inform we should call the
supervisor first
you're right that's a good move do i
have to pee now
no sorry i pissed my pants a little bit
ago super
i don't like that hey soups phone only
can be used to call supervisor
well good thing i need to do that a
dialing
get through hello speak
here is cemetery number four this is new
night patrolman i'm just getting ready
to patrol
when suddenly a big bag of corpses was
thrown in the cemetery
please call the police call the police
why
because this is killing and abandoning
bodies what should i say
uh the note and there's a note on it
signature is h yes how do you know to be
on the safe side
you need to burn these bodies directly
with the wood
next to the cabin for tomorrow morning
what
how is the lucy uh the lucy is real good
very cute
she's fine now well that's okay igloo
exclusion patrol
bye all right thanks boss really
appreciate it boss
good boss boss all right loser liz go on
patrol
it's ridiculous let's go i'd better wait
until the morning shift comes
actually it means throwing the mess to
the morning shift a roof
all right yeah i don't have to do
anything about that all right later
nerds i'll just write a crisp note on a
bag of corpses for the morning
shift to take care of all right cool
later
why the bag looks fine but traces around
the bag
it looks like a wild animal broke into
there damn there is blood everywhere
well there was blood everywhere before
lucy it seems this is your job
let's drive away animals from the
cemetery a roof
okey-dokey then here we go
oh i see blood i see blood i see blood
what is that how would anybody go down
[Music]
oh forward okay oh this don't oh
hello baby
a stone statue that can be seen
everywhere in fog city
i don't like the name fog city can i
just say that out loud i think fox
city's terrible name for his uh
for for our city it seems to have
specific local belief symbolizes life
and death creation and destruction
i am a foreigner and don't know much but
that's unexpectedly suitable in the
cemetery
is someone playing the didgeridoo
i'm not going to question late night
didgeridooing but
it don't seem good seems kind of bad
the path looks like in a cemetery to
avoid getting lost when i go back i'd
better remember the route
oh yeah oh i remember all right oh yeah
i remember
oh definitely remember oh yeah
big remember energy i call it
remembrancy
what the am i going the wrong way
maybe good thing i'm great with
directions
why is the route so complicated i don't
know
i do not know
[Music]
oh cat scream oh
what happened it sounds like a cat
well nothing else to do about that one
oh no wrong way
i went wrong way so many unidentified
corpses that they need to
yeah well mm-hmm
oh good i probably just needed to follow
the blood to be perfectly honest oh this
looks good what's going on the tombstone
was destroyed
it doesn't look like the cause of
animals for someone discarded dead
bodies and someone destroyed the
tombstone
no wonder the supervisor has to hire a
night patrol
yeah no wonder no wonder buddy
i'm never gonna remember any of this
there was blood everywhere
it seems to be animal hair on the ground
is this a bone come on lucy let's go
ahead and see
oh boy i'm never gonna remember there's
no way in hell
there's no way there is no way there is
a hundred percent
some of the graves were dug and there
was a gruesome stench
there's a source likely in it
who is it show yourself gulu
ah hello gulu cat not bad
cat oh that was not me i don't
understand what you're saying who are
you
is that yours what is mine give it to me
if it is fresh i'll share it with you do
you want head
or legs what no neither
neither neither
take the head head you
sow generosity not many meat on the head
i can give you a leg
oh oh oh oh oh
give me the dog let me help you
tear it off monster
you you want to eat lucy don't be
nervous
will you give your part no
oh i'll let you in just to you
ready to rush forth lucy wait monster is
too big
listen carefully there's an axe next to
the cabin you run faster and get it for
me
axe do you know what i'm saying you guys
disgust
who can i eat go get the axe you're okay
all right i'm i'm going i'm going i'm
going i'm going oh
god no oh okay i don't remember the way
are you kidding me i don't remember the
way was it this i don't know
am i wrong am i right oh no
oh god i made it i i don't i don't know
where i'm going i don't know what i'm
doing i don't know why i'm doing it
okay i might have been the next one over
no
it was definitely this one
oh oh i get another try good okay
i don't even remember what i did now
okay this not this one
not this one oh no wait was it that it
was that
oh god it was thatton oh i'm an idiot
oh wow i'm dumb oh wow i'm dumb
oh boy oh hey buddy hey what's up hey
how you doing uh
okay i got i got it i got this time i
got it this time third time's the charm
i remember exactly which way to go i
remember all of the exactly which it was
definitely
not this one it was all the way over
that's right this is the right and then
it was not this one
it was this one and then it was
the middle one and then it's getting out
of here time
nope i messed up god damn it hey
pal what's up with you hey how you doing
lixian ended this to make me look good
because this is not a good show
make me look really smart make my brain
huge bigger
humongoid massive
oh oh lucy you're back
where's the axe have you brought the axe
carry a bone bone
what i wanted was axe not bone
dog is here too lucy run
lucy looks very angry lucy
oh what the hell is it oh i don't know
okay lucy hey woof
eyes eyes didn't change yet oh
can you change body freely what exactly
are you
lucy is just looking at you forget it
thank you for protecting me
a woof you've eaten so much you still up
for dinner
yeah freeze frame
[Music]
that was great i love that oh wait what
i thought it was just chapter one okay
should i
i should prepare the feed for you first
okay lucy you're
great someone just clap at me
someone clapping whoa
hi barking oh my god what
not again
okay great good
that's fantastic that's really something
metal
oh hey what's up you the proprietor
seems that cutting the head down is not
enough isn't it
lucy lucy looks very happy
who are you did you know lucy lucy come
here
lucy leave the city if you don't want to
die
let's go lucy and we go to find an old
friend
her roof i'm guessing that's the
proprietor of the cemetery
the guy in the statue guy i i think i
should quit my job
[Music]
i love that i love that i love that
and uh you know it's amazing i got that
uh that last puzzle on the first try
really shows that my uh
oh my sense of direction is unbeatable
undeniably beatable
thank you for allowing me to express my
genius
great stuff play it in the down there
the description link all right goodbye
[Music]
so that was three scary games thank you
all so much for watching
um there's something i'm forgetting to
mention to you guys
i don't really remember what it was uh i
think it was important
uh lexi and what am i forgetting
something very important you don't
remember either okay
um well i mean at some point it's just
gonna
come to us so uh
you know it's all good just gotta wait
for a
what was tap that i'm forgetting
you